in braunschweig wird zurzeit die
genaueste uhr der welt entwickelte
taktet mit einer 10.000 fach höheren
frequenz als bisherige atomuhren und ist
dadurch 100 mal genauer jetzt können
abläufe in der natur gemessen werden
wie bisher unmöglich zu untersuchen war
dixon seine entwicklung herzlich
willkommen
wer eine apple bosch hat der kann am
pünktlichsten an silvester anstoßen
wie verfügt nämlich über einen
temperatur stabilisierten quartz
oszillator über den man sonst nur
deutlich teurere quarzuhren verfügen
normale funkuhren gleichen die zeit
nämlich nur ein paar mal am tag ab um
dann mit relativ ungenauen greifen die
zeit nicht mehr so kann exakt anzuzeigen
bei der apple boss ist das nicht der
fall
die zeit bezieht sie wie an ruhen auch
von times server die ihre zeit von
atomuhren beziehen aber die apple bot
mitte zusätzlich die temperatur um die
dadurch bedingten veränderungen des
körpers zu korrigieren legt man zwei
apple bot nebeneinander laufen sie
absolut pink rot das heißt aber nichts
gegen die atomuhr die zurzeit in
braunschweig in der physikalisch
technischen bundesanstalt ptb entwickelt
wird die wir 100 mal genauer sein bisher
funktioniert atomuhren folgendermaßen
auch wir haben einen temperatur
stabilisierten quaas oszillator der bei
ihnen allerdings keine uhr takte sondern
ein elektromagnetisches feld dem atome
ausgesetzte sie haben eine
resonanzfrequenz bei der sie besonders
viel energie aufnehmen und wieder
abschreiben mit dem kreis bilden sie
einen regelkreis in den immer gemessen
wird wie hoch die abgestrahlte energie
ist wer quarks wird dadurch immer in dem
bereich gehalten indem die energie am
größten ist
die taktfrequenz liegt dabei im
mikrowellenbereich in 20 millionen
jahren war ich um diese uhren um eine
sekunde ab exakter kann eine uhr heute
nicht sein in braunschweig wird jetzt
allerdings eine optische atomuhr gebaut
hierbei wird die resonanzfrequenz eine
sie uns mit hilfe eines hoch exakten
lesers gemessen
dabei ist die frequenz 10.000 mal höher
als bei bisherigen atom und die zeit gut
100 mal genauer gemessen dafür ist
jetzt an der ptb ein hoch exakter leser
entwickelt worden
wer ist der schärfste laserstrahl der
welt das besondere er strahlt nur in
einem sehr engen frequenzbereich und er
ist besonders stabil
die lichtwelle schwingt rund 200
millionen mal in der sekunde und kommt
dabei erst nach elf sekunden auf den
takt bei einer lichtgeschwindigkeit
von 299 tausend kilometer pro sekunde
ist der strahl seien schon fast 33
millionen kilometer lang auch hier wurde
das durch eine technik möglich die
temperatur aber auch druckschwankungen
ausgleich wie beim temperatur
stabilisierten quarz also siliziumdioxid
bei der optischen atome durch die der
reformator aus elementarem wie lithium
das als ein kristall mit einem homogenen
kristallgitter das noch zusätzlich auf
150 grad - herunter gekühlt wird und
von weiß mit schall und allen
möglichen umwelteinflüssen isoliert
ist die größte schwankt jetzt nur noch
um maximal zehn kilometer das ist das
zehnmillionste der größe eines
wasserstoffatoms und das ist ja das
kleinste atom dass es gibt er kann jetzt
für die neuen optischen atomuhren
eingesetzt werden und dort die frequenz
besonders exakt ermitteln dabei wird
dieser besondere laserstrahl durch ganz
europa geschickt so besonders ist er
damit optische atomuhr noch exakter
verglichen werden um einen noch
genaueren mittelwert zu ermitteln eigens
dafür wurde im september eine 1400
kilometer lange glasfaserleitung
zwischen braunschweig und paris in
betrieb genommen über die dieser
laserstrahl jetzt geschickt wird und
damit zwei optische atomuhr intakten
kann
jetzt können in paris und braunschweig
unglaubliche dinge gemessen werden zum
beispiel die unterschiedliche
rotverschiebung von licht die durch die
gravitation verursacht die
höhendifferenz zwischen den beiden
städten beträgt 22 meter und kann
jetzt so bestimmt werden
und jetzt kann auch die sekunde genauer
bestimmt werden
bisher war sie das 9 milliarden 192
millionen 631.000 77 70 fache der
perioden dauer werden über übergang
zwischen den beiden super feinstruktur
niveaus des grund zustandes von atomen
des nuklear 133 ps entsprechenden
strahlung war okay ich habe auch keine
ahnung aber auf jeden fall wird die
bekundet beiden neu definiert werden
müssen
in braunschweig hat also ein neues
zeitalter begonnen im wahrsten sinne des
wortes was ich noch alles ändern wird
das erfahrt ihr natürlich praktisch zum
teil zu entwickeln wenn ihr keine videos
dazu verpassen wollt dann solltet ihr
hier
ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
auf die plaques ja und hier geht es
weiter mit
da wars todesstern leser gebaut drauf
klicken und los geht's bleibt dran